so the state of feminism today I think
it is being renewed and redefined and I
am going to speak more from the American
perspective but to some extent the uh
the British perspective although in some
ways Britain is ahead of the United
States others it's it's behind so
renewed renewed precisely because yet
another generation of women has
discovered uh that know this has not
been fixed that in fact although they
were told when they're growing up they
can do absolutely anything and they are
equal with boys and if anything they are
outpacing boys uh in school uh and in
graduate school and I say I'm a feminist
by day and a worried mother of boys by
night and my boys sort of assume that
it's the natural state of the world that
the girls are smarter than they are in
school which the feminist in me loves
and the uh mother does not uh
so a new generation's discovered not
withstanding all of this we're still
stuck we're stuck at 20% women in a good
industry and in a bad industry 10% even
5% that is I think what Cheryl Sandberg
tapped into with lean in and other
people writing books saying wait a
minute you know we've got a we need a
new surge of feminism that's part of
what my art article uh triggered they
sort of red efforts to get women's on
boards uh to do what I call confidence
feminism right to teach women how to act
like men uh and to teach women how to
act like men and ask for what they want
and push themselves forward so that's
being
renewed I also think feminism is being
redefined well actually if I'm honest
I'm trying to redefine it but let's put
it in the in the passive uh uh voice uh
which is to say that I think if we're
going to get to full equality between
men and women which is really the goal
right that's that's what we want we want
full equality between men and women then
we have to focus Less on advancing women
to top jobs and more on valuing the work
that women have traditionally done the
work of care the work of investing in
other people and feeling as much pride
when they succeed as when you succeed
when you're raising children
or investing in in students or mentoring
people or at the other end of life when
you are in trying to ensure that people
you love and who cared for you have
their very best day every day and if we
value that work and we value it as
individuals as care is a huge part of
who we are and we grow when we do invest
in others just as when we invest in
ourselves When We Make Room for care in
the workplace we assume this is a
natural part of all human lives and we
are simply going to have to to
accommodated at different times in
different workers lives but that that's
a condition for everyone and when
nationally we invest in an
infrastructure of care and just as much
as we invest in the infrastructure of
competition that we know is necessary
for a healthy economy and Society so we
need to change the lens we need to focus
on valuing not just women for what they
can do to be like men and continue to
Value men but to Value the traditional
work of women and and we'll talk about
this that means valuing it when men do
it and assuming that men will do as much
care in the home as we now expect women
to bring in as much income in the office
so I'll stop there thank you very
much
and now for a historical perspective
we're going to turn to the prizewinning
historian Amanda Foreman who wrote the
bestselling book Georgiana Duchess of
devire which won the Whitbread prize and
more recently she presented the
acclaimed BBC documentary series the
ascent of woman which charted out rise
over the past 10,000 years please
welcome Amanda
Forman
I think that anarie has got to the heart
of the matter which is how do we
redefine feminism for the future and it
reminds me of a a well-known joke that
some of you probably already do know
which is U how many feminists does it
take to change a light
bulb and the answer is none it's not the
light bulb that needs
changing and the the the point about
that is that in order to redefine the
future you need to know your history
because if you don't know it then others
will redefine your history for you and
I'll give you an
example the the idea of patriarchy in
the idea that women have always been the
second sex is that true well the answer
is no in fact patriarchy is very much
the new kid on the Block if you go back
to only 8,000 BC and you look the oldest
town that we know of 8,000 that's not
very long ago in the great template of
humanity in 8,000 BC there's a town it
was called it is called chatah in Turkey
it had about 10,000 inhabitants and what
we know from that town is that men and
women did the same work in the same
place they ate the same diet they were
buried in the same place and in the same
way so that then at at the dawn of
civilization you have gender equality
and what happened next came many
thousands of years later and what that
tells us is that
patriarchy is human made and what can be
made can be
unmade thank you very
much our next speaker Helena Cronin is
the darwinian philosopher at the London
School of economics and she's a leading
expert on The evolutionary understanding
of sex differences and she wrote the
bestselling book The Ant and the peacock
altruism and sexual selection which is
one of the New York times's nine best
books of the Year Helena please give us
your perspective thank
you now why in medicine are men from
surgery and women from Pediatrics in law
men from corporate
women from family
Specialties why are the professions as a
whole split as they are nowadays 5050
male female but most professions and the
Specialties within them typically men's
or
women's why men at the top why though
the Sexes are equally intelligent are
there different male female
distributions at
all why do women but not men feel most
satisfied with part-time
work why the pay Gap and why are such
patterns Universal transcending
countries and
cultures the answer according to current
Fe feminism is anti-female bios and
barriers but that can't be the whole
story here's
why two things first the science of sex
differences
evolved male female differences in
interests and temperaments give rise to
different life priorities such as do you
prefer to work with people or things do
you favor plan ability or do you relish
risk
second organizational analysis of the
professions different kinds of work
intrinsically dictate different needs a
brain surgeon might meet expected
difficulties a lawyer work all night on
a client deadline it's not arbitrary
that they can't get home for
dinner now together these two insights
provide an immensely powerful framework
both explanatory and
predictive you can do the following and
we've done it in our research put in any
data from any profession in any country
at any period And The hitherto elusive
answ aners to those perennial questions
that I just asked and more will be
revealed feminism should take that
science
seriously thank you for that challenge
to feminism and now Daniel Glazer who is
a neuroscientist and is director of the
science Gallery at Kings College London
you will please welcome
Daniel
I hope is the only male on the panel I'm
not the pantom I'm villain but um I I
thought I would do a quick experiment in
in my opening bit just to prove a point
I want to make and the point I want to
make to you uh is that while we do
recognize differences in what women do
and men do and where they're found in
terms of professions and so on one of
the biggest challenges which I think we
have to overcome if the feminist project
is to succeed is differences of how they
are seen so the difference between the
way that women and men are seen and I'm
going to to claim that those differences
the difference seeing doesn't depend so
much on whether it's the man or the
woman doing the Seeing it's about
whether they're looking at a man or a
woman so what I want to prove to you
with a quick experiment is that what you
are seeing changes what you hear and to
do this I'm going to discriminate
slightly against those of you in the
back of the hall because I'm going to do
an experiment which requires you to look
very carefully at my lips and those
without binoculars or good eyesight in
the back won't be able to um what I've
done is to connect a Dev up here that's
going to amplify my voice and I'm going
to make some sounds and I'm going to ask
you just by a show of hand what you hear
from the sounds that I'm making okay is
that clear so you'll hear some sounds
and I'm going to ask you what the sounds
are ba
ba ba
if you heard da da put your hands up now
okay quite a few in the front if you
heard ba ba put your hands up now if you
heard something in between da and ba or
if you thought it changed as the speech
went on yeah changed the speech went on
very good so the experiment is proved
because um what I played you was a
recording I made earlier in the office
office of me going ba ba ba ba ba so the
sound was completely constant but those
of you that could see my lips moving
heard something different okay which is
why those in the front there was a
smattering of difference and you can do
this it's called the murk illusion and
it's very powerful example of cross
modal perception okay so what you see
changes how you hear and I think this is
an unrecognized problem in how women are
perceived in public I was the last thing
I'll say I was reading a fascinating
article last week from The Washington
Post Alexandra Petri wrote and she
imagined the following thing she came up
with a problem which I'm sure many of us
are familiar with a woman in a meeting
will say something simple like I don't
agree with you and uh everyone else in
the meeting goes whoa why are you so
aggressive you know hey calm down lady
we're all on the same team and uh in
fact to combat this she came up with a
number of key statements from rhetoric
and philosophy and she rewrote them in
the way that a woman would have to say
them in order not to be be perceived as
aggressive so I'll give you a couple
give me liberty or give me death was the
original one as a man might say it to be
perceived as non-aggressive a woman
would have to say Dave if I could just I
just feel really like if we had Liberty
it would be terrific and the alternative
would just be awful you know I mean
that's just how it strikes me I I don't
know for sure
so the kinds of perceptual differences
that now the differences that we're
talking about are cultural my friends
they do not arise in the womb uh and
they are not determined by biology but
they we see differently because we are
in culture to see differently this isn't
a re red green question it's about how
we were brought up but we do need to
think about these different perceptions
and notice that I think women and men
perceive the same differences we've got
to think about that as well as Behavior
if we're going to solve the problem
that's me for
now